what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right so yesterday Kaitlyn um at
that sea monster share link on Facebook
has her Facebook friend so that means
were real friends so she's shared a link
on Facebook about how John Krasinski had
been talking about how he wanted to play
Reed Richards in the Fantastic Four
reboot all right look here's the deal
man
John Krasinski this probably doesn't
mean anything if I mean obviously this
doesn't mean absolutely anything because
I am just a guy who talks about comics
there's a zillion of me on YouTube now
why is this in question why is this not
happening maybe it is behind the scenes
but like if I were working in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like if I were Kevin
Feige you know and like we go under like
one of those big board meetings and it's
like okay guys so we need to talk about
rebooting the Fantastic Four I would be
like John Krasinski and Emily Blunt done
now all we have to do is figure out
who's gonna play Johnny Storm and who's
gonna play the thing I'd be like that
this is what's happening right now like
this is the way it's gonna go all right
Gordon Gordon Wyatt Earp Gordon Show
people in this video a picture of Reed
Richards from seeker wars all right now
tell me people tell me this does not
look like John Krasinski tell me John
Krasinski could not play this guy I mean
he dude he looks the part man and if
like the reviews for the quiet place
were to be believed that movie is
apparently Jesus
it's got like a hundred percent on
Rotten Tomatoes I'm excited to see it
I've been excited to see it ever since I
saw the trailer it's a movie where they
never talk except for like I think one
point there's one point in the movie
where they say something and I think
that's it the entire movie is silent I
think it's like it's like directed and
written and like produced and stars John
Kruse it's like his first real outing in
a movie and like like apparently right
off the bat he hits it out of the park
leave it if that wasn't the case like
the guy made his bones at his acting
chops in like 13 hours and he made his
acting chops in like the office the guy
can act and then like you turn around
you watch movies like 13 hours and it's
like - man this guy is legit and in like
like to me it's really more than like he
just looks that way I mean there's no
downside here he looks the part the guy
can act the part and then Emily Blunt
like they're married so not only do you
have Reed Richards acting out in in the
movie you have John Krasinski playing
the role of Reed Richards who's married
to Susan storm in the movie he's married
to the woman playing Susan storm in real
life and Emily Blunt she is a beautiful
and wildly talented actress like it's
stupid how talented she is so like I
don't understand how this is like a fort
how this is not a foregone conclusion
like the only question that needs to be
asked right now by anybody in the
Fantastic Four film is like
who should play Johnny still woman who
should play the thing okay now here's
here's the deal here's the deal for me
this might be an unpopular opinion and I
know the people might not necessarily go
with it with the MCU but like I would
bring back Michael Chiklis like Michael
Chiklis playing the thing in the
fantastic four movies like the way he
was depicted there was just a byproduct
of Fox's inability to make good movies
like that that's all that was like Fox
did Fox cannot make a good Fantastic
Four movie anybody who believes that
Michael Chiklis cannot play a serious
character go watch the shield dude he
was legit like back in the day back in
the early 2000s when he wouldn't who's
in the shield here's one of the best
shows like like it's one of the coolest
shows that show felt like breaking bad
before Breaking Bad like it was it was
amazing like it was one of the coolest
shows out there but like dude I would
bring him back in a heartbeat I mean
outside of that the only thing I could
really think of would be to like CGI the
thing and have like Kevin Grove Oh like
voices character do Kevin girl oh that
guy's got the voice of God it is insane
through this guy's voice is so deep he's
got vocal cords they'd have got to be as
big around as like a like a PVC pipe in
a house it is insane but like there's a
handful of things you could do that for
me Johnny Storm is like the biggest
question here Johnny storms the hardest
person to pick who is Johnny Storm in
the comics like what's Johnny Storm like
in the comics well Johnny Storm is like
one part like class clown but like he's
got it where it counts right like okay
the moment that like solidified how
badass Johnny Storm was for me now you
know pardon my language but the ones
like the one thing life solidified how
awesome Johnny Storm was for me was
during Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
right we always come back to that
because it's like the greatest Fantastic
Four story ever I swear to god we've ran
over Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
so he times any chance to talk about his
Fantastic Four run is a chance worth
taking because it's like there it's like
dude it's like man it's like we're in
greatest stories ever alright there's
this amazing moment right like the
negative zone portal gets open and like
the Future Foundation and like Ben Grimm
they like respond with Johnny Storm at
everything they're trying to keep the
annihilation wave which is just like
this army of like billions of insect
bugs they're trying to keep them at bay
keep them from like spilling into the
main Marvel Universe like Johnny storms
like hey guys I got this I got this you
guys go inside I'll be right behind you
and I'll close the portal will close
when we get back in and they're like
okay and then like he just shuts the
portal down and like he's stuck on the
other side of the negative zone and it's
like the most badass thing ever because
it's like one versus a billion and like
Johnny Storm just turns around and
spectacular style he's just like flame
on and it's like the coolest thing ever
- the guy goes
so bad ass it's like dude it's like dude
like it's dearness it's like man it is
this guy man like dude like like that
moment right there in this story I was
like okay so like Johnny Storm is a
beast because like like to who do he is
and like like we don't actually see the
fight happening but like if we'd seen it
taking place dude it'd be one of the
most insane fights in the history of
comics it would have been so sweet but
like that's what Johnny Storm needs to
be in the MCU right like he needs to be
the guy worse like he's a goofball and
cat you know he can he can joke around
and be nonsensical but like when it
comes down to it like he's the guy you
want in your corner like like if you're
if you're going through and you're
playing kickball he's your first pick
because while he may go for round he'll
kick that right out of the park
that's the guy you want we need an actor
that can pull that off right we need an
actor who can be silly and goofy who can
make the audience laugh but who could
also be tragic and who can be serious
and in my mind there's no actor better
suited to play that role than Aaron Paul
dude okay Aaron Paul man look here's the
deal
I know you had that movie after Breaking
Bad driver or whatever it was which is
not very good in Breaking Bad like I
liked you more than I like to walk -
right Aaron Paul if you happen to see
this man write a letter stand out stand
out front and protest do whatever you
need to do man but like get the role for
Johnny Storm like could you guys imagine
that Aaron Paul is Johnny Storm holy cow
dude it would be amazing because what
you would have is you would have a
handful of actors all right if you if
they brought back Michael Chiklis
whatever it whatever was they ended up
doing you know if you had Michael
Chiklis playing a thing you had Aaron
Paul playing Johnny Storm you had John
Krasinski playing that playing Reed
Richards and you had Emily Blunt you
have a recipe of actors right there that
can keep that franchise going for
however in the how long they want to and
they've got the chops to make funny
movies they've got the chops to make
serious movies they have the ability to
act out those characters in such a way
that if Marvel wrote the movie feel
adequately and like one of them died you
would feel it like you would be like
damn do Johnny Storm died man but he
went out like a hero though like I mean
that's that's exactly that's how it
would be like like they're they're so
good so like like to me it's a foregone
conclusion that like John Krasinski and
Emily Blunt need to play Reed Richards
and Susan storm that is not in debate
like that that's not a contestable point
like that's just the way it is I mean
I'll be happy with whoever they picked
but if they come to me and they say Rob
Jefferson you are going to be
the one you are the absolute authority
you will decide who will play the
Fantastic Four in the MCU that I'm just
like John Krasinski for Reed Richards
Emily Blunt for Susan storm and then
like Aaron Paul because holy hell you
know and then like like Michael Chiklis
for the thing because you know he
couldn't the guy can obviously act and
place a pretty solid role that would be
my vote like that's what I would do and
I think it would work I think it would
be I think would be a damn good movie
like having these these folks come
together I think it would be an amazing
film but let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section because I'm
kind of curious I know that when it
comes to fan casting everybody has their
own favorite actors or actresses that
they want to see play particular roles I
think this casting is actually pretty
solid but still I know a lot of you guys
have like particular people that you
want to see play certain roles I know
some people aren't really fond on
Michael Chiklis coming back I know they
have like other ideas for who they think
should play the play various characters
I know there's some people who are sick
loads on Johnny Storm and they don't
really think Aaron Paul would be a good
fit I mean let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section
because I'm kind of curious cuz at the
end of the day that's really what this
is it's just a fan casting ranting and
raving about you know who's gonna play
who well that's the fun of it like
that's that's the whole fun is to see
like whether or not your opinions match
my opinions because that's basically all
these things come down to like people
watch season or just like it's like it's
like watching a top 10 list right like
okay like I will like the list but only
if your list matches my list if your
list is not match my list and I will
dislike it and I will tell you that you
forgot to include what I wanted from my
list because you know my list is
absolutely right I mean I do that I
don't know about you guys I do that
whenever I watch those top 10 list I'm
just like okay let's see if it matches
my opinion like you know I mean I don't
I don't do it intentionally I kind of do
it subconsciously and then I realize
what I'm doing at the end nonetheless
people nonetheless alright here's the
million dollar question we got it we got
an answer this here's a million dollar
question you can't have the Fantastic
Four without having Victor Von Doom
alright so here's the question who
should play the role of Victor Von Doom
in my mind there's only ever been one
person who should play the role of
Victor Von Doom and it wasn't the guy
from the Fox films there's only ever
been one man who should ever play Victor
Von Doom in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and that's vincent cassell
dude that guy looks the part like I mean
he's he's older now like he's got the
facial structure for it you know he has
this kind of like like if you go watch
it go watch like Ocean's Twelve
or like any of the other you know
independent movies that he's been in or
the mainstream movies he's been you go
watch like any film he's been in and he
almost has this kind of arrogance about
him I don't know if that's how he has in
real life never met him never really
watched an interview by him I'm sure
he's a cool guy but like
he hath he lucky he walked to this kind
of arrogance and that's how Victor Von
Doom is like dr. doom is a guy who's
just like okay so there's me and then
there's everyone in the world who's
dumber than me like that's how Victor
Von Doom functions and how we've used
everything he's always riding me for
God's sake the guy who first to himself
in the third person in his own comments
there's nothing more arrogant than that
like to me that's what's so cool and I
think that like he would like vincent
cassell could play the role perfectly so
so here's what we would have you'd have
a Fantastic Four movie with John
Krasinski and Emily Blunt playing Susan
storm Michael does playing Reed Richards
and Susan storm Michael Chiklis playing
the thing Aaron Paul playing odd playing
playing Johnny storm and then vincent
cassell playing dr. doom that to me is a
recipe for like a mind-blowing
blockbuster Fantastic Four movie it
would be insane but I don't know let me
know you guys think that in the comments
section if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys have to hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
Court if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you